- He's an American skateboarder,
actor producer entrepreneur,
and reality TV star.
He's one of the biggest
supporters of professional
skateboarding and one of the sports most
well known characters.
He was labeled one of the most influential
skateboarders of all time by Fox Weekly.
He's Rob Dyrdek and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
- I think when it comes to understanding,
tackling fear and
relentless problem solving.
The reality of learning tricks,
you have to try it over
and over and over and over.
Keep adjusting every
little aspect of your body
to ultimately get it to work.
When you get it to work it's like,
this incredible oh my God I
can't believe I learned this
and that progression
drives you even further.
(rock music)
I've always been,
have an idea and execute it to a fault.
What I had to learn over
the last few years is
you can't do it by yourself.
I really would have said years
ago I don't do it by myself.
I got all these great partners
but the reality of it is,
I would have my hands in
so much and not delegate
properly and put in the
right verticals on how
and what you want to accomplish
and go out and accomplish it.
I just willed everything into existence.
More than anything it's about
what do you love to do the
most and what are you best at?
Do that all the time and
then put everybody else in
to fill in the rest.
That's what I've really been focusing on
these last couple years.
Make no mistake,
even every person that I
want to move forward with,
all I care about is your
greatest quality is that
you want to get better
tomorrow than you were today.
(rock music)
It was that
big step for me to have money to start
exploring different entrepreneurial,
darts if you will,
at a skate shop that
lasted about three months.
That was where I first discovered
stay out of retail.
Started a hip hop label.
Had a rap label for a little while.
That's when I really
discovered the importance of
making sure your partner
that's equally as motivated
and driven as you not lazy.
More than that,
stick in your lane.
Just 'cause you think
it's cool that you're a
pro skateboarder and
you got a hip hop label,
you don't know what you're doing.
You got no business in that.
In that time period I had
refocused on just all things skate.
(rock music)
There's this air of transparency.
The entrepreneurs that I love the most
they'll be honest about everything
and they'll tell you exactly
how it is good or bad
and will just put a stake
in the ground on a opinion
but not drive it home.
That's the stuff I respect the most.
(rock music)
The greatest energy that
you can live in is that
excitement of something
coming around the corner
whether it's a
new job or a new moment of
something big happening.
There's that energy.
I've figured out how
to live in that alive.
I think that becomes
incredibly motivating.
Then when you see the results
of making yourself better,
how much better you get
and how it affects the world around you,
it just gives you that
much more motivation like,
if I just get better and better
everything gets bigger
and stronger and better.
That motivation and drive
comes from that desire
to grow and create.
Where I ultimately see myself
I just haven't quite got there.
(rock music)
For the most part I don't
take meetings before 11.
I build my whole schedule around
my morning and the working outside of it
just so it's not compromised.
The only way it really becomes compromised
if you begin to schedule
into your time.
For me it's really important
that I really don't
take a meeting.
If that's shooting TV,
doing voiceover doing whatever.
Whatever it is it never
happens before 11 down here.
(rock music)
I have had so many failures
at so many levels and I think
I only really started
to get it and grow up
a year and a half ago
when I finally brought on
a CEO for my company.
He really began
to help me learn to continue
to grow and then start
surrounding yourself with
mentors and really smart people
that have done what you're trying to do
or what you may want to do
so you can learn from them
and that really revolutionized
my entire process
because before I was making
millions losing millions
making millions buying this doing this.
I wrote produced financed films.
Lose a couple million like (mumbles)
I was so driven that
it didn't matter to me.
I just wanted to get things done.
(rock music)
What you never want to
do is put unrealistic
expectations on somebody
that you're trying to
do business with because
it will strain a friendship.
You got to be smart to keep people
in their lane and have them
excel at what they're best at.
You don't want to have someone
in your particular crew
take over the accounting if
they're bad with numbers.
The same way you don't
want them to do design,
if they suck at designing,
just 'cause you need someone
else to work on design stuff.
I think in all aspects of
life it's always much funner
when you surround
yourself with people that
you enjoy being around.
(rock music)
You have to focus on always learning.
It's cliche but the reality of it is
is if you take action and try and fail
you're going to learn a lot
by the time you try it again
and you will build a
foundation of experience
that's going to be ultimately
the rock that allows you
to find success or follow your dreams.
(rock music)
I don't know if I've always though global
but I've always thought big
and I think the difference
is now I have it so clear
on what I want to do for
the next 10 years that
I've slowed down because
I know I'm building this
great machine and
it's going to take me a couple years
to get it perfectly in order
before I finally turn it on.
When I turn it on
it will be bigger than
anything I've ever done
or ever will do and will
ultimately represent my legacy
and I realize that's cryptic but
that's how far out I'm already
prepared for what I'm doing next.
(rock music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video because
Jorge Gallegos asked me to.
If there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Rob Dyrdek's top 10 rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments.
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching Dreams To Believe
and I'll see you soon.